Main battle tanks of the t72 type which were destroyed on
March 31, 2022 in the Battle of Kiev
by an
anti-tank mine on which it drove,
at least parts of
the crew presumably died in there too,
so ultimately we are also standing in front of
a soldier's grave a little way from that
is the whole point of the action the
spectators and citizens
walking past the demonstrators who will
come later they should also be confronted with the
suffering that this war has caused
another detail
that may still be of interest
the tank comes from a Russian
tank unit of the  in boazien is called
that believes or withdraw
is exactly stationed that is very relatively
far to the east uh the boaten are an
asian minority living in the
russian federation and in the
context of this war especially in the
context of the offensive of
last year disproportionately often
also died, that's why
this tank also stands a bit
for yes, the colonialism that is connected with the
Russian Federation and its
history,
yes, very briefly about me again, my name
is Enno Lenze and
more or less that was my idea  let's
not say my exclusive
idea, but I had
seen similar exhibitions in Kiev, I've
been to the Ukraine since March last year, also a lot really in the
front area, i.e. in the chamber choirs
krakev in Butcher a day before the name
became known
nikolaje before rulers
was liberated and so that means I
saw all the suffering, the destruction and such and these things that are difficult to
convey, like when you are somehow
shaken out of the hotel bed by the
impact of a rocket because our
windows somehow blew up in our ears
how can you  On the
one hand, convey to people that
the war is cruel and brutal, but on the other hand,
without these classic shocking images, like a
child in parts or something similar, because that
doesn't help to convey the center point,
because when people turn their backs, it's so disgusting
that you just don't see it  I want something that
is easy to understand and
how do you express something that you
would like to express? I find that
extremely difficult if you don't know how
other people spent their lives
and what you understand about it, but
I thought you could see a destroyed tank there
that it's just broken something trivial
may be this side here still reasonably
good that doesn't say it's a shame that it's so
high otherwise you would see that
everything
is broken diagonally up here at the back, so to speak, up to the front it
hit the mine it's
like that  a tank there that breaks
down very quickly in war, even if it was
previously thought to be destructible for us
and this transience, so to speak, of
man and machine that is
sadly good to see here,
so you can imagine
wild forces must have been at work there and
that  a tank like that
burns out immediately the tower was also flown off
because it's no fun we have to
collect the towers afterwards and
put the flies on the right tank
sometimes 100 200 meters away you ca
n't imagine the force that
works there
NASA that uh that shows such a tank well
that I can convey well with it and
the idea actually came up last June
when I contacted
the Ukrainian embassy who
answered within minutes who
has been incredibly helpful to us ever since  As
you can imagine, the
ambassador has a lot of appointments today,
so that's not right here,
but of course we are very, very
grateful to him for helping us,
of course, to the
military history museum of the
Ukrainian Ministry of Defense
who lent us the whole object
and you lent us  helped to get the thing here
that's um I
've never done anything like that before maybe
someone of you has experience with that I won't
tell you anything new but
there are now around 1000 pages of
documentation to drive the tank over
with things that  you can't
imagine how many permits
and permissions and questions you need so
i think we've roughly said what it's about we do
n't want to keep you
busy with long speeches here
don't worry we'll stay until
every question is answered by everyone
so  once again to explain dr Patrick
Heinemann the conqueror of every office
[applause]
and quite honestly I can drive a tank
around but he makes it possible for him to
stand there that is the decisive point
then Wieland give curator of
we have enough I am very sorry I
just thought we have an air raid yeah
it's very deep in your head if you
know the sirens then it's an air raid
she doesn't
think we're going to have an attack now I think that belongs
to another protest action I was
just irritated and wanted it in the middle of
the  Bunker well that's how long
Giebel the curator of Berlin Story
Bunker who, among other things, made the exhibition
Hitler How Could It Happen
and a lot of other things in the
field of war and
conflict research and I'm the noenze
I'm the museum director of Berlin
Story bunker and roughly speaking what my
idea is to put this thing here but
we can also halfway
explain each other's subject areas to him we
had a little more contacts last
year then thank you again for
freezing your fingers here and being
so good and  listen, thank you very much
to them too and from now on we are
available for all questions
explaining why this animal is on top there
so forgive the animal up there
the stupid mutt Wien just someone
somewhere behind us called that is a
so-called napo-feller
it is  a bit complicated and
to sum it up very briefly it's something like
a
mascot of the Ukrainian
resistance that's how you can roughly
summarize it and in detail it's a
bit longer
to he as a Berliner thank you together
question yes we approval on March 8
of the liberation
we want
is better  this is not a question with
workers that their tank
tanks at the soviet once in the
tiergarten so the question is can we put
this tank at the soviet
memorial in the tiergarten i would
say the driver can do that
but i think dr patrick heinemann
says no and if he doesn't  can then
no one can be good nor
the tank what happened afterwards
first he goes to the
freedom museum in the Netherlands and they take care of
a road trip in the Netherlands, so to speak, that among
other things with a former
NATO general and the former one
former
manager of the Special Monitoring
Mission in Don Bass and there are
a lot of very good people there who will be
seen in Den Haag and Amsterdam, among other places, but that will be cleared up
afterwards, through other European
countries and at the end potentially in a
tank museum  Germany there, so
to speak, everyone said we were
interested, but first we want to see
that the thing arrives and then we'll talk
more about
the tank, we
already explained it at the beginning, it comes from the battle
around Kiev, from
dimitrovka, the name of the place is,
so to speak  if you drive out the tournament highway in
the direction of the tournament and then an
exit to Butcher to the right there
is that there is the exit after the
voucher with the destroyed things and
then another 10 km further you come to the right
after the exit which is an arch to the
voucher there  it was shot down
but if you get around there is a plan
everything is fine
yes we financed it that is
a very very sad chapter if you
ask my bank that is from your own
bank account so it is completely 100%
your own money but we
started crowdfunding  We still have
a lot more ideas and we are
always happy when someone helps us to
finance such things,
so the first question I repeat you
asked me to what extent the
Foreign Office was involved
because it
could possibly affect foreign policy issues
yes, so that this action could affect the
foreign policy interests of the
Federal Republic of Germany that would have been
claimed by the district office of Berlin in particular
since thrown into the
market bowl just not the
freedom of opinion and um yes
the foreign office has never
made any positive or negative statements in any way again the
foreign office was
not involved as far as i know other
federal ministries were definitely involved,
especially the
federal ministry  Economy and
climate protection because there you have to get a
so-called
militarization certificate
if you want to
drive through Germany with a destroyed battle tank
because then there are many places,
especially customs but also the
police who would like to know
that the tank is no longer dangerous
but that the  only has scrap it
is also somehow understandable that
what I don't drive every day
but there we received a lot of
support the
cooperation with the Federal Ministry
for Economic Affairs Climate Protection was
really excellent and it went very
smoothly and uncomplicatedly
and yours  second question was
why the tank is now pointing in this direction
there are very simple reasons these
are static reasons ultimately yes
it wasn't so much
that they said we
really want the pipe to
point to the Russian embassy we
can  so as a result would live very well that would
not want to
start no aggressive war let me say
yes then there is no tank
but I think they are mainly founders
of statics that is not
primarily intended as a provocation but
the tank here  As a Lenzer said earlier,
the S-Bahn tunnel runs under here, the north-
south tunnel, and uh, there are very,
very strong restrictions and the
heavy weight of the tank is right here,
and that's why he made it
necessary for the pipe to point in this
direction
next question next question please
no questions
from the press please
then I think that was the
general stuff then we'll come
down to you now and then as I said
now we'll do the questions who
has lengthy statements just
send them by email we'll read them later
[music]
[Music]
Berlin Mitte try to block and the
white Center lorias
like you know if you passing you could
be so shock that basically drop from
[Music]
Erdzeit 72s
in the battle of Annette and over mind
in March last years and the  first of the
moment
on the fans of your cranet things the
when to McDonalds when it blue up and
nobody was hurt that was
on Portugal
you welcome
okay okay
of course Berlin Story news and Faser
News Outlets in the Germany
March when it started to Kiev when  the
Russians world retreating from we went
on first to the basically everywhere
and then Johannes was treated who
like show showing whatsapping
you welcome
now do it starts
tomorrow at 4:40 a.m. and
has been alone for a week what is
the source of what  and then
my girlfriend put us here
because they were kind of worried it's about to
start it was so clear on the way
because we're always worried
when we really have the news